i remember speaking to you and you're
like i can't enjoy a game if i if i'm
not making someone else's day
be worse okay
okay okay i said that to you as a joke
but that's kind of true right
like there's just something that like to
me and
maybe this is again coming back to the
episode where we spoke about chess right
like
to me gaming has always been a thing of
like it's like a thing where i can
i can learn a skill i can get better at
that skill and then i can beat others
yeah right and like you know sometimes
you play a game of league of legends
and it feels like you're playing the
piano like it feels like you're just
crushing them
but then when you when you get when you
lose it's not a good feeling
yeah i i want to play a game and i want
to beat other people off the top he
wants to make someone else's day worse
yeah
that's how he gets enjoyment exactly
like as well like
if i play league of legends i can't play
normal games like
like i need to play a ranked game
because i know that people will will
give a [ __ ]
because if people aren't giving a [ __ ]
no one's invested right if i
if i [ __ ] die a ton no one gives a
[ __ ] a normal i mean they do but i don't
give a [ __ ] yeah but if i die in a
ranked game i'm like [ __ ] i think that's
why i've never got into pvp games
really it's because i've never given a
[ __ ] really yeah that's probably why
i like i can't like i don't give a [ __ ]
do you not like refining a skill like
getting good at something and like
that's not what i play games for i mean
that's what i do i play games for
for [ __ ] escapism right but then i
guess my form of escapism is
learning the skill and having that
gameplay loop of doing it over and over
again and then going against other
people
no i don't have that because i don't
give it because like in my opinion the
reason why i love jrpgs is because
there are no bragging rights with jrpgs
by finishing a jrpg it's not like
yeah i beat this game like that's why i
beat persona 5 like five times it's it's
not because i wanted to brag to people
that are beating five times but because
i wanted to see the route
but you just bragged about i'm joking
yeah i just did it
but no it's not it's not for bragging
rights i don't do it for that and i
don't do it to
feel superior or anything i just do it
because to me i guess
gaming for me the way that it's been a
an escape is that
i get to sink myself because i'm i'm i
need to be challenged constantly
yeah and when a game doesn't challenge
me in like either mechanical skill
or like mentally like i'm just not
invested because i'm like it's not
challenging me
i need something to challenge i mean
this is why i like play instruments
right
so that i could get that side of my
brain focused yeah right yeah
but then i guess we're all different
right like for me
i think maybe escapism and you do have
that part of you want to challenge
yourself but it's it's satisfied by just
learning
an instrument or playing an instrument
but for me it's like i think it's way
too consuming for me
like yeah i'm way too competitive like i
was that one [ __ ] in school
who turned everything into the olympics
i was like
i was always that one guy yeah we're
doing a light jog oh
oh we're doing a light jogger and then i
would [ __ ] sprint right
yeah i remember like okay if this
doesn't explain how like competitive i
am i don't know what will
in school when we used to do long
distance running i was terrible at long
distance running okay but you bet
every single time we did it i made
myself throw up i was so desperate
i was so desperate to win the long
distance running that i would literally
every single time we ran i would push
myself into the point of throwing up
because i wouldn't stop i wouldn't stop
right you don't miss
and i remember it literally became a
joke at some point that every like
because every year you would do a school
thing
yeah yeah yeah and i remember i would do
the 400 meters and i would not stop
sprinting
the whole time and i would literally get
to the i would sprint the whole hot 400
meters to win
i would stop and i would just go
because because i was pushing myself way
beyond what was needed
yeah because i in my head it was
embarrassing to lose
i mean like i get people okay and before
anyone thinks wow man connor your
parents must have raised you in a way
that made you think but nah dude my
parents were like yo connor calm the
[ __ ]
like my parents were like where did this
come from because we're not like that's
interesting you say that though because
then now i'm wondering why you're so
heavily into arc nights
because nights is a pve game not a pvp
game but but it's still got
i i think i know because it's still got
like challenges in there and arc knights
is the
worst [ __ ] like combo for you because
it's a game
that you can't win unless you spend more
money yeah and then even if you spend
more money
you still can't win and and and there's
a whole bit of enjoyment by following
the story
i didn't follow the story i mean you
know i've
you know i've leveled 95 and arc nights
but now that i've beaten all of episode
six and done all the challenge modes i
kind of woke up the other day and i'm
like
i don't know what have i got to do i've
done it i've done it
i've done it i'm in the end i've
completed
the arc but like that's the thing right
and then i think
i also destroyed any chance i had of
liking story games because
when achievements were a thing on xbox
360. yeah you bet i was that [ __ ] who
was like i'm going to want
all you were the achievement hunter yeah
yeah yeah and i got way too into some
games and
i remember i got so frustrated with
jrpgs because i would just buy any game
but it was due to research which games
were easiest to get an achievement
i didn't do that i just bought a game
and i would complete it but
[ __ ] jrpgs man they had the worst
achievements they were like collect
every one of this item
and then you would go to the guide and
be like oh well seven of these items you
can only get
at that time and if you didn't get it at
that time sorry kid you got to restart
the game
and i'm like i hate you who did this i
hate you so
so much i think that was the saving
grace for me that i never owned like an
xbox 360 or a playstation like i never i
never played on a console that had
achievements i was always just a
nintendo kid so it was literally just
you versus the game yeah i wish i did
that because
i remember i got an xbox one and one day
i was like why am i
why am i getting these achievements like
what am i what am i what are we doing
like like he had the feeling like
there's there's achievements to be
gotten here
i can i can perfect this skill to get
all of the achievements
oh dude okay now and it's on it's
challenging this is a challenge
and then i look back at all the [ __ ] i
did like i beat the lost video game
the [ __ ] lost video game and i
remember
that even i didn't even know there was a
lot even my 15 year old self could tell
this video game was not a video game
like this was
garbage dude and and i beat it just to
get that 1 000
i hated that game